[Music]
[Applause]
he's max crosby the las vegas raiders
defensive end pro bowl defensive mvp and
a uh fourth-round pick out of eastern
michigan and uh max joins us on the
program i believe is max ready
he's coming down the hallway i hope he
didn't go to the traeger grill
we'll get some more phone calls as well
uh adam sandler on the program tomorrow
come on in max uh ed orgeron former lsu
coach joining us
hi bud what is up how are you doing i'm
doing great doing dre
uh well we got some uh got some jewelry
on today
what are you gonna what's the what's the
most expensive thing on you part of the
watch i just got it how much is that
it's more than i would like to pay
you know
every year i gotta after the season i
have to you know i always get something
just kind of yeah okay but
do you have to clear that with anybody
when you make pictures oh yeah yeah i do
you know i do a very good job of you
know managing and keeping things in
order but you know once in a while you
gotta you gotta spoil yourself a little
bit you're kind of a breakout star this
year
do you feel that way
um you know i
nationally nationally yeah i've noticed
you know more attention and things like
that um but for me it's just
you know i try to
stay in the day as much as i can i don't
try to look too far in the future too
far in the past so you know obviously
it's awesome getting the attention and
things like that but
staying humble and staying staying
grounded is just as important now i
don't know how valuable it is to be the
most valuable defensive player in a pro
bowl where nobody tackled anybody max
but i mean
i don't know where you put that trophy
in your trophy case when they go oh was
that the pro bowl where nobody tackled
anybody okay who who lets everybody know
what was the agreement where we go
we're just going to have two hand touch
honestly there wasn't an agreement um
once the game started i got off the ball
and i noticed everyone was kind of
moving in slow motion so i was trying to
like act in a way to try to you know but
after as the game went on
you know there was a big bonus so you
know vrable was a competitive guy he
wanted to win everybody on our team was
like all right we're gonna like kind of
go with the flow but we we wanted to win
so yeah you know there's a couple third
downs and fourth downs where we kind of
we're rushing a little bit okay but for
the most part somebody had to go
we put our the officials had to know
this as well
when mac
mac jones is running and then they put
their hands on they blow the whistle
yeah i'm like
and mac he keeps jumping uh you know
he's going towards the end zone yeah
that was a tough thing is short yardage
was the hardest thing of the whole game
because you get to fourth and two or
third and two whatever you run the ball
and someone just touches the running
back it was done so you basically had to
throw the ball every single play so it's
kind of a fine line did you talk amongst
each other
no really there wasn't any agreement or
like a common ground it just everyone
was just kind of chilling the whole time
so it was yeah that's different tell the
story as you've i'm sure done many times
this week now you got the extra x in max
yeah so
as a child you know i was uh as i was
being born i was 12 almost 12 pounds
and i was stuck in my mom so i was
literally
couldn't they couldn't get me out my mom
almost
killed my mom so they had to break my
shoulder to get me out and
my mom is i was being named obviously
they knew i was going to be max but they
put an extra x on there once they asked
because i was yeah that was double x so
it kind of
you know it kind of worked out you know
how i might add another x on there but
then that might have been that signified
a different career therefore
yeah catapulted to me yeah
where i needed to go
also uh tell me if this is correct that
uh you weren't the most famous guy in
your high school
uh no i wouldn't say so i feel like who
was the most famous person in your high
school from my high school
um
that's tough
christian ponder was a oh okay a former
collierville heritage guy was there
somebody i feel like you know somebody
that i don't know and that's i'm
probably going to get in trouble now did
post malone go to
no he went to grave on arrival oh a
rival yeah but i'm a chiefs fan too
cowboy fan i thought he was a chief fan
no didn't he go perform with the uh
chiefs when they won the super bowl he
might oh he might have done that if they
pay him yeah oh but he's a cowboy fan
he's a die-hard cowboy fan unless he
changed i don't know i haven't don't
talk to him you know how these kids are
nowadays they change
i got your draft profile there there's a
piece of paper right there
now
[Laughter]
this will be good i'm excited
so aaron rodgers has done it von miller
j.j watt they've all done this
uh so you're you're in line with some
hall of famers there we just talked we
just took the bad stuff that they said
about you coming out of eastern europe
this will be good all right so you ready
yes sir all right go ahead
all right
dominated smaller competition and hasn't
been tested by lead blockers
i understand that somewhat okay to a
degree
gets caught standing up out of his
stance which is
disastrous for a small chest
are you small chested i guess so okay
that i've never heard that one before
though
that was weirdly descriptive now these
are real
profile
we'll struggle to control the point as a
pro i've
yeah i heard that a lot
lacks explosiveness out of his stance
forcing him to play catch up coming off
the line
that's tough i don't know you ran a
4-6-40 i believe that's tough i mean
that your biggest weapon feels like
being explosive i feel like at that
especially at that time i was a lighter
guy but you know
that's what it is
um can be tight in the hips especially
early in pass rush
what does that mean i don't know what
that means i guess a little stiff is
what they're trying to say but i don't
know what early in pass rush means
i don't know is that early in the game
or i i don't know okay either early in
the game or like early in the beginning
of the play or something i don't know
okay what else that's interesting uh
running backs and quarterbacks break
from his clutches oh interesting
wow not in the pro bowl they didn't
yeah i guess so yeah
exactly
elementary rush
elementary rush approach and fails to
use hands as consistent weapons i think
i know who wrote that
and yeah i think i do okay but i won't
name them because
yeah but that's actually that's funny i
like that
wow which one bothers you the most um
i think the elementary the elementary
rush approach or the
small chested defender yeah the smaller
chested i've never heard a guy described
as small chester that's wow pro comp
jeremiah
um let's do the max crosby max bench
one rep
paulie you go first
oh boy i'm gonna go
475 i might be low 475 benching wow
that's a lot of weight seaton i was
going to go 375. all right fritzy i'm
going to say 410. it's small chester he
was small
i'm going to do one bench one rep 340.
it's probably around there yeah yeah i
haven't done a sing like a one rep max
in a long time but
probably be around three yeah probably
343.50 somewhere in that range maybe
more maybe less i don't know strongest
guy you've played against
um
[Music]
probably
probably tyrone smith oh yeah he's his
hands are
the strongest things i've ever felt
touch my body
if we play dallas this year me and
yannick after like the first series we
both we were flopping sides we came to
the bench we looked at each other like
bro you gotta just
if his hands are on you it's over
it's over yeah he's it's
i don't even know how to explain it you
can't move
so yeah you gotta
speed the power on him it's the only way
do you hold grudges
do i hold grudges uh not anymore i feel
like as a younger guy i used to care
about everything but if somebody cheap
shots you in the nfl um
goes at your legs or anything like that
not really i'm used to it i feel like
that's like tight ends i know they're
going to go with my legs because they
don't want to you know
go chest to chest with you so well
you're a small chest yeah small chesses
so i guess maybe not but
yeah you know i don't hold grudges like
that you know i feel like i tend to get
over things pretty pretty quick uh
you're joining us on behalf of uh
reframe yes sir you want to give the
spiel
yeah we can give a quick little rundown
you know uh
reframe best uh best sobriety app in the
world um you know just it gives people a
tool
you know to stay sober it's a community
it's gotta um
you know they do a great job you know
for me i'm a guy who's a part of that
community almost two years sober so you
know this app is a is a great uh great
thing for people when did you know you
needed help
um
honestly i feel like since the day i
when i first started drinking i knew i
was a little bit different than
everybody i couldn't handle it um the
same so
yeah you know it just it just got
progressively worse as time went on so
once i got to that point where i just
looked myself in the mirror i was like
what am i doing you know i'm in the nfl
i got a lot of things going for me
and it was the one crutch i've always
had so um it got to a point where it was
just unmanageable so you know i had to
had to make a change but also we use it
as a crutch because sometimes we're
in on social situations like you lean on
a beer yeah you know that hey i'm now
funnier or i'm more
engaging with people did you do that
yeah you know i feel like
it that's the thing like you talk to a
lot of people who have drinking problems
or
smoking whatever it may be um
it helped them in that way like for me i
know
it was like my saving grace as a young
kid because i was insecure growing up
and things of that nature but once i
took that first drink i was like oh my
god this is my thing like i was in love
because i could go up and talk to that
girl that i wanted to talk to and you
know things like that so yeah you know
early on it was like it saved my life i
was i needed it but then after time you
know time goes on it just became
something that was continuously holding
me back
how important are tattoos to you
um i've always loved tattoos when even
when i was like young in high school
you know my first tattoo i literally
took my brother's id and he looks
nothing like me
and
i went into the tattoo shop and they
just looked at me and i was 17 and they
were just like all right and just let me
let me do it so yeah
i don't normally look at a man's thighs
but i'm looking at your thigh yeah is
that is that a
a map yeah so i got michigan here in
texas here and i've i'm getting the
whole my whole legs done and everything
so yeah it just hurts so i haven't
finished it yet
oh the thigh hurts a lot horribly yeah
the thighs are terrible the back of the
neck terrible
okay but why do you do it if it hurts so
bad i just like how they look you know
but i don't like going through the pain
i try to get numbing cream but it wears
off after a while so you just gotta you
gotta suck it up what's the one where
you went home and mom went what are you
doing
um
[Music]
i don't my mom is like
my like best friend so she's like
she wants me to do stuff like that like
if i if i love it she's like oh yeah go
do it max like i was a kid and she i
came home with a big tattoo my first one
was on my forearm i just punched myself
in the chest
it's i got this big one of my grandma my
great-grandma um on my forearm and it
was just i was in high school and she
was like oh i love it
she was encouraging me to get it so like
my mom yeah my mom's awesome she in that
way she's just she she's like my biggest
fan and my dad was just kind of sit back
and be like he doesn't really care yeah
he's like all right do whatever you're
gonna do
uh it's great to great to talk to you
congratulations on all your success um
you can hang with us as we get ready to
close out the show fritzy on the show
tomorrow is we've got uh adam sandler ed
orgeron and drew brees
once again max was joining us on behalf
of reframe and uh for more detail
reframe.com can you go to that max do
you know if the
yeah so it's an app so you can go to the
app store download it and uh yeah it's
smooth reframe map reframe app great so
uh what we learned brought to you by
butcherbox uh we got the meat outside on
the traeger grills you should stop out
and get some grub there max
butcherbox.com patrick to get two pounds
of ground beef free in every order
that's coming up thanks for joining us
we'll talk to you tomorrow right here on
the dan patrick show